bienvenue sur le plateau de face cachée
lorsque l'on parle de mon invité on dit
ici ray alors c'est vrai qu'il l'a été
la voix des matinales de radio
martinique pendant quelques années c'est
albert auguste nous allons bien sûr
découvrir sa face cachée du sapet le
portrait qu'elle nous présente pierre
lafarge nous son vrai nom emmanuel
auguste albert nôtre mais né à pointe à
pitre le 13 janvier 1958 il a tout juste
18 ans lorsqu'il fait ses premières
armes à la radio alors au lycée de
baimbridge auditeur attentif il gagne un
concours radiophonique ce qui lui permet
de se rendre à la dominique et de
visiter les studios de radio gembo nous
sommes en 1976 les radios libres
n'existe pas mais sur les antilles de
nombreuses stations se sont installés
albert avait été trois mois pigiste à
fr3 guadeloupe mais rejoint droit
l'équipe de patrick meyer fondateur par
la suite de radio 7 et rfm en région
parisienne une grosse tête
albert auguste va à radio antilles à
monserrat travaille à radio caraïbes et
en 1986 à rfo radio martinique pour la
station de clairière il a d'abord
présenté une émission de variétés
trempolino mais les auditeurs le
retrouverons et ce pendant plus de 15
ans sur l'antenne radio tous les matins
albert a le truc pour réveiller la
martinique dès 5 heures avec différents
rendez-vous dans l'horoscope le seul
horoscope au monde ayant tracing le
lapin est en plus pour les végétariens
dit il il est vrai que albertis irait
rasta il l'est aussi du genre à préférer
malcom x à martin luther king mais il ne
se servira jamais de l'antenne pour
faire passer ses messages
l'antenne il exploitera au maximum sera
numéro un dans les sondages en studio
mais aussi lors des podiums rfo radio
bleue il sera sollicité pour de
nombreuses animations commerciales mais
aujourd'hui albert a quitté ses
émissions quotidiennes pour d'autres
fonctions à la radio il a tout de même
conservé une place dans son agenda afin
d'animer une vacation hebdomadaire sur
radio martinique et quel est le thème le
reggae bien sûr retrouvons albert
auguste raux nelly saint père voici face
cachée
bienvenue albert jeunes est ravie de
recevoir un homme de radio mais aussi
lui qui a aidé également télé alors la
pince égoutter les pâtes et les revend
parlais tout à l'heure la peste quelle
date la paix génialement cet effet
février là entre le buzz qu'il y avait
la baleine ça c'était pour les navires
rainbow way he à commencer par la
questionnette va répondre par oui ou par
non d'accord et donc tu devenais le plus
martinique a développé un jeu peut dire
oui ni non parce que c'est pas vraiment
vrai c'est vrai que ça fait longtemps
mais bon alors la radio
au plus tôt au plus tôt la micro tu te
manque beaucoup
oui la migros et tu de ceux qui pensent
qu'on ne vit pas dans ce métier là les
métiers de l'audiovisuel en règle
générale n'ont qui m'ont dit oui
grâce à sylla stano 6-6-6 auto son tour
ouais halle berry fly
ça a été le passage de ces matinales a
alors tu nous as tu nous as dit
effectivement que ça te manque beaucoup
mais tu es sans vraiment y être mais bon
tu tues tu suis un petit peu la radio ça
a été
passage en vue du passage de passage de
témoin comme comment ça s'est passé
vous allez dire bien puisque quelque
part j'ai choisi fly pour moi en place
est bon parce que c'est un bon animateur
et j'aime son style l'animation ça s'est
passé j'allais dire d'une façon se doit
c'est après que les douleurs sont venus
ressenti ce moment là j'ai pas eu à me
réveiller le matin quand j'ai eu à
écouter la radio c'était assez
inhabituel généralement je faisais la
radio j'ai failli se réveiller tous les
matins très tout ça c'était pratiquement
nature c'est à dire que je suis habitué
c'est une seconde nature jeux mauvaise
un problème est maintenant donc je suis
obligé de faire du sport le matin au
m'occuper quoi ouais ouais ouais
qu'est ce que tu as aimé c'est le
rapport avec ces gens parce que j'avais
de super le rapport avec les gens ont
apporté des légumes des sous des gâteaux
des machines de ce texte consiste à
continuer le monde vingtaine nord il y
avait le rapport avec les gens mais y
avait surtout la radio quand je suis
finalement un homme de radio j'aime
beaucoup la radio m
tous dans la radio c'est à dire au faire
être animé mettre de l'ambiance faire
découvrir des choses puisque pire a dit
john booth et ça avant que j'aimerais y
avait quand même une petite épisode
effet à trois voies de l'opa l'époque
c'est pour te dire que ça remonte mais
là j'étais du côté des journalistes au
côté de l'info et je trouvais ça un peu
trop rigide
c'est l'histoire de rédacteur en chef
qui contrôlent ce que tu vas dire les
choses comme ça parce que c'était bien
20 80 donc ça m'a pas plu du tout donc
je peux faire l'animation et avec
l'animation c'est vrai que je me suis
éclaté depuis pratiquement 25 ans ouais
alors tu me diras stassi et quand on
parle de rasta si on pense évidemment le
nom romano panoplie pour nous mettre
dans l'ambiance de l'ocs s'exciter allez
vous retirer votre bol c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
toi
[Musique]
oh
non
hu
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
non non
toi
dommage
x
[Musique]
et
oui
de c
[Musique]
c'est moi
m
[Musique]
avant
et
m
[Musique]
l'auteur y forma
aux rails
c
[Musique]
oh
pour toi
[Musique]
ouah ouah
ice avait précisé la foule m tu l'as vu
en concert dans les années 80 tout le
monde c'était grandiose quoi et puis je
regrettais toute ma vie bobby miles soit
dit en passant parce qu'il n'y a pas
qu'un baume
j'aimais aussi beaucoup miles davis
ouais j'ai eu la chance de voir les deux
ça c'est un gros grain plaisir c'est
bien pour un animateur présentateur
d'avoir justement ces espèces de
rencontre
de l'expérience de concerts ou autres
devoirs de voir plus ou moins
d'approcher un artiste que vous parlez
obligé déjà de par la profession parce
qu'il faut aller les voir et fois la
rencontre de nouvelles trouver des
interviews amené des choses nouvelles
pour les auditeurs en même temps c'est
bon pour nous aussi de voir ce que
dégage d'artistes pour le retranscrire
après radio ce style là est-ce que tu ne
le ferait aujourd'hui aller vers les
artistes allaient à la rencontre
d'artistes
ces choix du même si je continue même si
tu n'es pas les aliments quotidiens
entre les artistes a dévoilé côtoyé
aléas des premières des vernissages des
choses comme ça comment s'est fait le
déclic du ciment polar pour la radio est
ce que c'est parce que tu t'es un petit
garçon qui aimait parler qu'ils aimaient
bouge et qui aimait voir les choses qui
étaient chez eux je vous parle non sa
part d'un d'une rencontre avec une radio
qui était monté à la dominique dans les
années 75 s'appellerait de jumbo et je
vais gagner un concours à l'époque sur
bruce lee et j'ai de découvrir j'ai
découvert donc à la radio avec tout ce
que c'était très dur complètement
différente des jalles rfo ou défaire 1,3
à l'époque tous telle radio les gars
fonctionnel un dj où il était logé dans
un hôtel pour relation derrière oui et
puis c'était un autre trip c'était
c'était la formule américaine de la
radio donc ça m'a plu tout de suite j'ai
dit aux gars bon ben il faut que je
viens de chez vous il me dit mais non
c'est pas possible on a déjà nos
animateurs nos journalistes savent
maintenant étonner puisque c'était
prédestiné
comme dirait l'autre alors petit cette
petite séquence souvenirs pas tant que
ça lorsque bon tu es à continuer cela
quand même jusqu'à l'année dernière sera
double c'était radio bleue sacré moment
mais ça me fasse alors c'était le
contact avec le public cette fois ci
voilà parce que c'est sûr que tu
travaille en permanence pour les gens il
ne voit pas souvent donc radio bleue
c'est à dire l'occasion rêvée de les
rencontrer d'être avec de passer parce
qu'on passait quatre jours dans la
commune
et puis en mai le podium matin après
midi après des rencontres formidables
d'invités chez l'habitant non c'était
quelque chose de bien un bar à double
sur la télé
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'appréciation même approche nous
allons faire la fête ça c'est super
marrant
l'actice oumou wane homeaway
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sous
il
ouais ouais il y avait une voiture
formidable c'est simple et c'est sur la
place de la mairie et j'ai beaucoup aimé
soit dit en passant j'ai des pantalons
pas possible oui je constate c'est
quelque chose avec ben stiller paulo
sylvie la grosse machine la grosse
machine qu'est ce qui te rend triste
albert beaucoup de choses la justice je
me dirais c'est un lieu comme le dit
souvent mais c'est vrai il ya plein la
barbarie des choses comme ça la
profitation comme on dit en créole c'est
vraiment profité sinon ça va c'est de ne
pas être triste quand même parce qu'il
ya tellement de choses pour oublier tout
ça tu père de famille quand il regarde
ce qui se passe dans le monde on parle
beaucoup de violence on parle beaucoup
des guerres on parle beaucoup de ces
choses là comment vois tu l'avenir
justement pour ton enfant oui j'avais
dire avec mes gènes quelque part ils
risquent rien donc je suis serein de ce
côté de 25 fois voilà c'est une question
de foi c'est une question de voix aussi
je vois comment ils viennent comment ça
ça n'a pas de problème pour faire pour
participer à une grande cause en fait
c'était cette cité une heure c'est une
sorte de transition par les durs de
grandes causes comme le téléthon qui a
participé avec tes les jays il suffit
d'un petit rien justement pour été les à
cette façon à 3 de montrer justement de
façon à nous parce que dans lost une
grande équipe c'était carrément rfo
radio et télé et puis albert qui
chantent ils auraient pu faire mieux qu
un équipage a fermé avec le micro mais
c'est vrai que c'était très bien sa télé
diez il suffit le petit rien
[Musique]
si la tête s'est passé n'est pas compté
mais on y acquiert ou gagne au change
richesses si vous partagez
[Musique]
et
qui sont petty qui s'en est fait pour le
mot de changer
pas manchot non ainsi a été
fidèle
ces bois landes c'est ça nous pas
mauvais c'est la vie
si chacun a ses bras
qui prend le pas
sur l'a8
[Musique]
donner juste un peu de soi
ne serait ce qu'une froid aujourd'hui
à quoi bon
soir
il atteint
[Musique]
le faire
trottoirs
pour finir par croire et cuisez semble
qu'il n'y a plus d'espoir au bout du
couloir
il suffit pourtant d'un petit rien
dans
dung
d'une main
il suffit pourtant d'un petit rien
[Musique]
soit féraud
c'est la vie
si chacun recevra
un jour tu prend le pas sur vannes
[Musique]
oh
c'est un peu le soir
[Musique]
une fois aujourd'hui
il a même changé ouais c'est une
tendance
quatre navires aie aie pas bougé
alors pas jouer soit laissé des messages
qui vous paie ou même si les faits
relatés mars
[Musique]
clinique et notre script en ce moment
d'ailleurs la surprise était rose une
rue alors justement parles tu parles de
surprise tu parles de grands moments
notamment comme si la question des
grands moments de ta vie mise à part le
cette rencontre avec le micro avec la
radio
et maintenant que tu es plus que c'est
ça c'est un grand moment parce qu'il ya
de bons moments souvent mais dégage à un
moment précis je sais pas ça veut dire
petite vie au quotidien avec tout ce que
tu prends de positif aux réseaux sociaux
comment vois-tu justement la fin tu nous
parles de ta vie tu nous dis pour tous
arrivés le matin mais maintenant je ne
peux plus aller le micro à ses cadets
maintenant c'est bon un peu ensuite
ensuite commence commencé dès qu'on
prestation ensuite je suis ici de
pratiquement dès 8h30 à 14,13 des x 13
14 l'après-midi au beau lot et là il
n'ya pas de quoi ça peut être du 19 du
verre ça dépend de ce qui va faire quoi
qu'en réalité je m'occupe j'avais 10 ans
pratiquement de tout ce qui concerne la
radio et l'écriture si tu vas à
l'antenne des animateurs l'éditorial et
choses comme ça et puis on a moins il
faut préparer des choses il ya saint
pierre il ya le carnaval tu vois il ya
les vacances
donc c'est du boulot comment es tu
restes ajustements dans cette villa
parce que tu diras stassi mais comment
vis-tu justement le fait d'espoirs à
stable on soigne ses locks ont filmé le
lem on fait quoi est ce qu est ce qui
concerne on se soigne déjà indépendants
model look se soigne déjà
spirituellement
on utilise ta bible du prix entre autres
louis gill mais ça c'était bien avant
d'être resté aussi je veux dire j'ai
toujours prié j'ai toujours pas lu la
bible si tu veux mais j'ai toujours
cherché est bon il ya c'est vrai
beaucoup de réponses dans la bible
beaucoup de rêves pour segal mort dans
d'autres livres 1 pas spécialement là
bim tu peux lire aussi la baja voir vita
jeu par le courant ce que tu veux on y
cherche trouve de cette manière et moi
je pense qu'on peut pas être et
non pas de reste à ce qu'ils ne savent
pas de sens et chez qui est dédié aux
couleurs vert jaune il faut qu'il ya des
blagues aussi les soirs à ça c'est pour
toi représentait avant du black
ah oui absolument c'est être fier de ce
que je suis déjà hélas la place de hailé
sélassié la place de tout de tout cet
cette philosophie rasta aussi entre
danton
se passant par national et sélassié
c'est le premier et puis il ya les
autres qui viennent
c'était le wade web je sache
ouais ça j'essaie de faire la
comparaison par la bible par rapport à
jésus christ qui a été ici considéré
comme le roi des rois sms cap important
que je peux l'être qui a dérivé l'achat
qui se font je veux dire à des périodes
où à des époques différentes
jésus christ et à un moment c'est là
c'est un autre moment et puis en aura
d'autres alors on va retourner un petit
peu dans la maison parce que tu es
chacha us ce moment ce moment télé
trampoline aussi de rappel de défauts
comme ça avait à l'époque dit aux
procureurs que je voulais absolument pas
quitter bercy
voilà un ouvrait la porte d'entrée ça se
passait très bien et puis le directeur
de l'époque pierre girard m'a dit mais
non rien on a besoin de pointer les tout
ça je suis venu pour la télé ça des
trampolines voilà mais ça n'a pas duré
valeureuse paulino avec albert
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir
et surtout merci merci d'être venus si
nombreux
trampoline au numéro trois d'un démarre
tout de suite trampoline au numéro trois
c'est une affiche bien sûr de choix avec
des jeunes artistes des jeunes artistes
vous allez loire bourré de talent
oh
le sol est la plus appuyée
je t'écris pour
que sais je
vous me suivez toujours alors le dieu de
la soirée premier richard et rose avec
une superbe composition de richard au
corps est le type pas flipper richert et
rose
[Musique]
des cendres n'a pas choisi
tlj
[Musique]
gauthier pour 86 quand même faut pas
oublier ça te plaît mais aussi
probablement des artistes en avait quand
même mylène du cloud ça n'aurait pas les
mêmes moyens s'est bien amusé tout
meilleurs alors je suis toujours dans le
doute dans l'amusement chat cas toujours
ce petit mot pour faire rire encore
faire quand tu veux qu'on te faisais les
matinales taper le nom parce que je suis
un bonne raison de plus que moi si on
allait mieux vaut je dis oui à oublier
semaine dernière pour nous j'ai
répertoire de blogs si tu veux juste
alors dans ton quotidien c'est un petit
peu donc cette espèce de superviser la
radio qui signera et les femmes les
femmes où la femme moi je dirais que les
femmes parce que
jeudi on ne vit pas aujourd'hui
seulement je vais passer et puis
intervenir donc nous on les femmes dans
ce cas est-ce que le fait d'être à
albert saah sah et des avantages plus
auprès des mines est moins sûr près des
femmes ouais
et comme je suis pas tellement mines est
donc marqué un but aux femmes oui voilà
donc vie sentimentale tranquille où on
ne doit pas se cacher au mois d'août à
face cachée à toi donc ses loisirs qui
tire le rideau
j'ai choisi d'être monsieur tu vas
beaucoup apprécié wycleaf jean joly oui
je lis est venu en guadeloupe a pas ici
malheureusement nos voisins on a dit que
le concert était superbe
j'espère oui on espère aussi on arrange
rsa là il sera avec l' idée avec beenie
man et celles aux mineurs alors d'en
parler de femmes c'est parce que c'était
aussi encore pour trouver une transition
pour montrer que ceux des petites femmes
donc
elimane et wycliff pour notre invité
[Musique]
minimes et la paix
oui
[Musique]
finalement j'allais la blague à
l'antenne je vous la raconte récep adobe
le pack wii
j'espère que tu aime beaucoup la merci
pour bunny boy ben oui ça pas qu'ils
s'étaient hissés parce que terminer je
sais que tu aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup voyagé en tout cas cela
caraïbes déjà tu as aussi cette
ouverture cela car elles contiennent
beaucoup un temps dans ta musique dans
ton choix musical mais également ce
fastidieux que je connais bien la
caraïbe pour avoir vécu si tu veux à
montserrat la dominique à sainte lucie
parce que ce qu'on a oublié c'est
qu'avant 80 il ya un système de monopole
qui faisait que les radios privées
étaient généralement à l'extérieur dans
les ide en ex anglaise comme on dit et
j'ai découvert des gens vraiment
formidable on a vraiment eu du bon temps
que ce soit à montserrat la dominique à
sainte lucie ou même ailleurs un petit
goût et c'était encore visitées comme
comme il est peut-être cuba et la
république dominicaine je ne connais pas
les pleins de choses en tout cas ce
samedi
merci à toi il n'est pas trop tard mais
nous on dit ça toute l'année
super merci de faire plusieurs tonneaux
oui ça va poser des questions précises
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup albert
merci beaucoup à vous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine mais surtout pour
notre face cachée
[Musique]